The human population is constantly growing.
And it maybe time to look into other places to live including underwater.
A Japan-based construction company has unveiled its design...
...for a subaquatic city that can accommodate up to 5,000 residents.
The proposed city is being called the Ocean Spiral.
Three sections will make up the structure.
A floating sphere or pod that has a diameter of nearly 1650 feet...
...will rest just beneath the surface of the ocean.
The pod will contain both residences and businesses...
...with a spiral path connecting the sphere to the seabed.
This will allow scientists to utilize energy resources from the ocean floor.